luke and jake here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel
and we're here in the desert of western
utah
and we are about to go camping in an
underground lava tube
we're going to see a whole bunch of cool
stuff are you excited jacob
yeah all right let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
lava rock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey you wanna go check out some lava
tubes why don't you put on your backpack
here okay
we're out in the middle of nowhere so
i'm gonna turn on my garmin inreach mini
so becca can track our location and i
can call for help if i need
look at this look at that
that's crazy you see another lava tube
now don't get too close to the edge okay
hey look jake there's a big lava tube
over there let's go check out that one
yeah that's a huge lava tube
the edge can break and fall down
follow me jay
thank you
yeah look there's another lava tube
right there
you okay bud
[Applause]
look at this this is so cool there's
miles
and miles of these lava caves here and
uh some of them are pretty collapsed and
others are pretty stable and i want to
camp inside the lava tube not only is it
really cool
but the wind is howling up on top of the
plateau so
i really would like to be sheltered but
i don't want to sleep somewhere where
there's big boulders
falling off the ceiling so we're going
to try to find a cave that doesn't have
a lot of cave-ins
should we try another spot yeah all
right let's go back up
well me and jake don't have a lot of
time to explore tonight because it's
already 7 p.m
we drove for three hours on those dirt
roads
to get here this place is not
not easy to access so we're gonna kind
of
find our campsite mate camp and then
tomorrow we'll have
all the time in the world to explore the
lava tubes
and some sand dunes some cool rock
formations and even some historical
sites nearby
look at this
sun's starting to get low we gotta find
our campsite quick
this one's not terrible but there is
still a lot of debris
knocked down down there let's try
another one jake
i think this is perfect jacob you notice
how there's lots of rocks
in here this part caves in a fair amount
see over here there's not really any
rocks
in the middle there so the odds of
getting crushed by a rock are a lot less
all right let's go ahead and explore a
little bit
well this ceiling looks pretty solid up
here
and you can see there's no rocks on the
ground so nothing's falling off the
ceiling in a very very long time
so i think this is where we're going to
make camp all right let's uh
all righty i got some really awesome
lightweight camping gear that i'm
eager to try out for the first time
today it's gonna be an interesting test
run
you know a great thing about sleeping a
lava tube is you don't have to worry
about staking down your tent
heck the only reason why we're using a
tent here is so that we don't have any
scorpions or snakes or mosquitoes biting
us in the middle of the night
i'm seeing one and you'll buzz it right
in the house
all right guys let me show you some of
the gear i've got i've got this nemo
inflatable pillow
it's made out of fabric instead of
rubber and it just feels really good
especially if you don't inflate it all
the way i even got a little one for
jacob
i've got the sea to summit ultra light
inflatable mattress
i've been using this a lot and i really
like this thing it
is comfortable and it comes with this
little inflator pouch
that you use as a pump to inflate it
it's about three times faster than just
using your breath
why don't you go and sit on this mat
here
can you even use my pillow now hands
down the lightest air mattress on the
market
is the thermarest neoair uber light
this is an entire air mat
but they make kid size ones which is
really nice
so this is going to be jacob's you can
blow it up by mouth which
isn't a lot for the kid size one or they
have this inflator sack you can use
one of the new products i'm excited to
try are these down camping quilts from
enlightened equipment
so you go and you slide your air
mattress inside the camping quilt
and it's got these little clips and
there you go
so basically you have a down comforter
that's attached
to your camping mattress just like that
the logic behind these is that they're
lighter and smaller
than a sleeping bag they're also more
versatile so in hot weather
they're really nice because you can use
them just like a straight blanket
people who find sleeping bags
claustrophobic or they toss and turn a
lot and they get
bound up in their sleeping bag they tend
to like camping quilts better but uh
i'm going to give it a try and this is
my going to be my first time sleeping in
a camping quilt
yes got our beds all set up should we
get some dinner are you hungry
yeah all right i bet you are
hands down the lightest smallest stoves
on the market are these little isobutane
stoves
i mean they only weigh a few ounces they
cost less than 50 bucks
and they're just so easy this one's got
a little barbecue lighter clicker thing
on it we're gonna see if it works
oh that works like a charm
that looks like that's boiling you want
beef stew
or do you want lasagna
of course you want lasagna all right
we're eating lasagna with meat sauce
tonight
we'll just seal that up
does that taste good bud
that one was hot
hey jake you would you like a roasted
marshmallow
show
there you y'all
you like your marshmallow oh there's a
mouse there's a mouse running around the
bottom of the lava tube now i'm glad we
have the dent
there he is that's easy right there
he just ran up everybody let's get ready
for bed okay
slide on down buddy yo is that cozy yeah
well other than all the little creature
noises we had a good night's sleep uh
woke up a couple times because i could
hear a mouse chewing on a log
and the bats would come in and make
their little squeaking noise and they'd
be flapping right above the tent
and at one point there was something a
little bit larger they came in and
smelled us and then took off but uh
nothing really messed with us
so it wasn't bad it's just kind of wake
up yeah what was that
but it sure was nice to get out of that
wind last night man it was absolutely
roaring out here
well i'm gonna let jake sleep in as much
as he can because that boy needs his
rest but as soon as he's up we're gonna
need a quick breakfast
and then we're gonna go and check out
some really cool stuff
there's some sand dunes and dried lake
beds
and some cool rock features and even
some historical sites nearby
we got a full day of exploring the
desert before we can go back home
good morning jacob
i'll tell you what after one night of
using this sleeping quilt i really
like it it's really comfy and it's very
lightweight very compact so
it doesn't take up much room in my
backpack so i might be using this thing
a lot more in the summertime
got some blueberry granola with milk
excited for some breakfast
yeah here you go bud
nom nom nom nom nom nom nom
this backpack i'm using is from gossamer
gear and it's one of the best
ultralight backpacks on the market it's
just so comfortable and just weighs
nothing most the gear here is kind of
expensive
ultra light backpacking equipment now
normally you don't need stuff this
expensive in this light if you're just
hiking by yourself
but when you're hiking with little kids
and you're carrying multiple sleeping
bags
and you need like a three-man tent and
all that stuff suddenly
having ultra light stuff becomes really
important so since my boys have started
to get into hiking i've become more of a
connoisseur of high-end
backpacking equipment
all packed up i think this weighs about
14
15 pounds
would you like all right let's just
check to make sure we didn't leave
anything behind
good looks clean all right shall we go
back to the car
this is why you need that light backpack
because i got
34 pounds at jake to carry two oh you do
not want to fall
down
you all buckled in bud yep good and see
we got your camel pack set up on your
car seat so you can drink whenever you
want
nice we got a couple hours of
serious four by fouring to do
there's just miles and miles of these
lava tube formations i mean more than
you could ever explore
just look at them we can hike for days
out here and never see all of them
[Music]
my two oldest boys tommy and nathan
they're in school still so that's why
it's just me and jacob camping out today
my boys are stuck at home doing online
school but
uh school's gonna be out here in a week
or two and then we're going to have the
whole crew
exploring and camping and doing
adventures with us
oh guys this summer is gonna be so
amazing we've got some great trips and
amazing videos planned for you guys
we're gonna be traveling and filming in
16 different states we're gonna be
climbing mountains floating rivers
we've got some incredible road trips
we're gonna be noodling catfish
it's just it's gonna be awesome if you
follow us on facebook we post a link
every time i post a new video which is
every saturday morning
every once in a while i'm seeing these
horn-toed lizards running across the
road i'm really trying to keep a sharp
eye out
i want to catch one
this whole desert we've been exploring
is part of an ancient lake called lake
bonneville
and it used to be the size of about lake
michigan
and right up there that hill that hill
is an old volcano and that's what caused
the lava tubes
about 15 000 years ago it exploded some
pretty cool geology here in utah
[Applause]
look what i just found
it's a mule deer antler nice one too
you're a deer i'm gonna walk up here for
just a second
this is pretty cool but i want to be
careful with my father-in-law's car so i
think i'm gonna walk up this hill and
check it out first before i try it but
it's not too bad i think we can do it
without being rough on the car
oh look at this
what a beautiful place just saw this
little rock formation decided to go up
and check it out i'm so glad i did
all right let's keep moving
hey look a little cottontail rabbit
this is really fun but it can get
sketchy quick if you break down out here
you could die of heat stroke we haven't
seen another car in 24 hours
additionally if it rains out here all of
these trails will turn into mud holes
immediately
and then you'll get stuck out here
luckily we've got a bunch of water and
emergency communication devices and
there's no
rain forecast for the next few days so
we're in pretty good shape
jacob come check this out right up there
there's a big pile of sticks
that's the nest of a golden eagle right
there
see look at that it's a little jawbone
of some
animal the eagle aid got the bones of
little birds and mice and stuff
from the leftovers from the eagle's nest
and look it's like the rock is just
melting and dripping down the cliff
tell you what that was pretty cool
look at that hey jacob look what we got
ahead we got a dry lake
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh that's fun all right there we go
that's a little homewash to my
brother-in-law matt
[Music]
i speak sheep
[Applause]
see we just drove over what's called a
cattle guard
the gaps between the metal bars are wide
enough the cow's foot will slip down in
it so the cows don't want to walk on it
but you can drive a car over it it's a
way to keep cattle penned in but let
cars through
that's the first car we've seen in 24
hours
guys this is the topaz mountain japanese
concentration camp from world war
ii on this location thousands of
japanese
americans from the west coast were taken
from their homes and relocated to the
desert here
in utah and forced to live under guard
and barbed wire
for the duration of world war ii
this is where the internment camp
hospital was
you can see kind of the old roads and
it's all set out in the grid pattern
this thing was the size of a
small town
japanese spies and saboteurs had helped
the japanese attack pearl harbor
so when world war ii started the us was
afraid that
japanese spies would do the same thing
on the west coast
so all japanese people whether they were
americans or not
were rounded up and removed from the
west coast
and forced into settlement camps like
this one here
out in the middle of nowhere
as far as your eye can see it's old
abandoned roads and broken foundations
lots of people
see this whole entire camp we just
explored this little tiny bit of it
look at this
[Music]
there's the car all the way down there
oh
we need to get headed home so i'm gonna
call for today and i hope you guys have
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every saturday morning
and if you guys want to see
more adventures from our utah trip i'll
put a link down in the video description
below as soon as that video posts
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching